foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
Side Track show and we got our friend
Sophie with us hey came all the way down
from Michigan this is her third time
here the second time being on the show
actually yeah that's right and um we
went out to mannequins last night had a
whole Adventure is that is that what
we're calling it
I got into two fights scored two
victories not a scratch to myself Jenny
got her ass beat well I mean look no not
really not really dude had her down on
the ground and then other [__] before
I could get to her [__] whole crowd
of people [__]
before that about a couple hours before
that
I was like pulling security they're out
there dancing and I'm watching them they
got all these randos in there
and uh I'm just keeping an eye on making
sure they're behaving
the randos we know how to we know how to
behave yeah one dude who's like six
something [__] walked up behind Jenny
and grabbed her ass I was on him like
Hey yep [__] went up there in front
of his friends and slapped him like a
[__] a full-on [__]
I said you grabbed my wife's ass again
I'll kill one of your friends
and that that descent that this is he
didn't mean no harm by it he says I will
kill him I love what
like that you know being harmed by it I
was like and I so I was telling Tom
before the show I said tell you what I'm
gonna randomly go around the club and
start socking random dudes in the balls
and say what what I didn't even harmed
by it yeah it's just a thing that I do
yeah
like what the [__] don't like keep your
[__] hands to yourself why is that
hard I don't understand why some people
have I mean I thought we learned that in
kindergarten right yeah
you know what
just
accepted
I thought eyeballs was going to be a
trouble but after I whipped that one
dude's ass but I've always wanted to be
my friend he's like dude I saw the whole
thing man that was great
that's great man don't forget if
anything ever goes down I got your back
it says oh we're hanging out now that's
what I'm thinking about your [__]
eyeballs
it's like we've been watching you've
been watching you [__] trying to move
in sideways you got an extra girl
available don't you yeah get the [__]
out of here dude don't do it boy
holy [__] it was funny I mean well I
thought it was funny
it wasn't funny for Jan no it absolutely
was not funny what happened with that
it's funny now but it wasn't funny last
night at all
look at that
yeah we need to expect because John
Smith said well that sounds like a story
they could use with some expanding yeah
yeah oh we're gonna tell you the whole
sorted thing like this one by blow this
was fight fight two of the night yeah
because the first one was just it wasn't
really a fight you just went up and
that that ended it right there yeah he
didn't like fighting
[Laughter]
um uh the second one
it has some dude he was probably about
how would you say five seven maybe
okay so this dude like I said he came up
to me earlier he was yeah I'm five seven
so like yeah five seven five eight maybe
okay all right about five seven five
eight hey these big old like Jeffrey
Dahmer looking she's like Square I
couldn't tell how old
he was he was either really wasted or
high you couldn't really tell he was he
was late 20s early 30s
um
he's still there with eyeballs he's just
walking in a circle around him while
they're dancing and [__] and I'm still
concerned well he was coming like right
up here yeah right earlier he walked
right up to me he just looked at me goes
wow you're beautiful could you be like
yeah don't do that I was like thanks and
just moved out of the way man the man
I'm telling you guys don't do that all
right uh ignore women basically
if they're not showing any interest just
then just leave us alone for Christ's
sake
if they're not giving you any attention
they don't want you
um so
the
he walks around one time [__] guess
what I've been doing this is okay I was
leaning up against the wall just letting
men be man but there's certain [__]
you don't [__] can only go for so far
when I start seeing
Jen or any of our friends start going
hey you know and the dude doesn't take
notes getting uncomfortable because it's
like you're trying to dance and just
kind of like be yourself and like then
you just have to do like encroaching
like on your space there's Unwritten
rules club culture like quit get out of
my [__] dancing so I walk up and get
in between him and them
and start dancing when he starts going
around me
so I just put my hand on his chest and
pushed him back that was warning knocked
that off what did he do he turned turned
around and then came back right that's
what I saw you do that and I was like
that I mean look at you like you know
move get going out and then I think he
was like
he's like kind of putting up like a
piece I think he was gonna kind of come
like yeah I saw that like out of the
corner of my eye yeah I ain't gonna talk
to you there's no there's no negotiation
there's no negotiation there's no with
me there's no if there's one warning he
came back I clocked him right in the
face
I'm just beating the [__] out of him and
then I got him in the headlock like that
like that and around that time I'm
getting swamped by my friends trying to
stop trying to stop it and then yeah I I
tap Jenny because I my back was turned
we were dancing and I tapped her and I'm
like look look and I turned around and I
was like oh [__] and like I went over
there I put my hand on Tom's shoulder
and I think our friend Anna was there
too and we were just like no I made it
like it's not worth it like don't start
a fight or whatever and that's what
they're saying but none of that's
happened to me I'm steady what happened
because yeah yeah yeah I remember doing
that and then suddenly we're not
entirely sure this happened because it
was like super quick but the guy got
away from you somehow because they
pulled me off yes five of them that
pulled me off and he was starting to
fall because his Bell was so badly wrong
I think he was halfway knocked out and
we were fighting over a beer bottle he
was splashing the splashing that beer
bottle on me and I was trying I tried to
grab the bottle from him because I was
gonna break it over his head you know
but yeah but then the next thing you
know they'd pulled him away or no he
fell away they pulled me yeah
please like runs right into Johnny just
he's like tackling me yeah exactly she
hits the ground yeah yeah I just fell
like I went over on my back and the
dude's like on top of me going like what
like he might beat her I'm like what the
[__] is happening right now it happened
like immediately and I got like
five people holding me back yeah one of
them is a girl who's a friend of mine
this biker chick who's cool she's a golf
Banker chick and she's trying to talk
sense to me I just [__] grab her toss
her and go [__] get out of it she's I
apologize later because the dude's on
the ground beating up Jenny by the time
I [__] got and it was only like two
seconds or of me yeah I mean it seemed
like a long time to me because I was
like I had no idea yeah I was like how
the [__] did this happen just now as
soon as I got loose and started heading
towards him a crowd of people just
[__] was
whisked him away they were also beating
the [__] out of him as they were taking
him away well I gave him I gave him a
good kick too after they had him down
real fast real fast yeah yeah They
Carried him out I saw that like bodily
and then I was just standing there and
[__] she's on the ground
so we picked her up and I found a cell
phone and [__] everybody's I don't
know whose cell phone that was it wasn't
mine they said it could
have just got thrown out maybe no no
well then all these psycho fence came
and was kissing everybody's asses and
[__] you know
and then it's towards the end of the
night it was like at least yeah it was
like one something
but yeah like a couple of a couple of
the goth chicks there they kind of like
pulled me over and they sat me down I'm
worried about Jenny
Jenny that wasn't fair she was just
dancing yeah I went yeah and she's the
only one well she was the only one on
the hit she was the only one on our side
that got hurt I was totally unscathed
because you were prepared
he's just like what yeah I didn't know
what was going on and like the thing
about it like he's just on top and I was
just like what the [__] is happening
right now and like I didn't
um I I remember like putting my hand out
like a claw and uh because I was going
for his eyeballs is what I was trying to
do and I think I got a thumb like in
here or like up his nose or something
like that and then like a bunch of
people like you know because of you know
some people that we knew were there and
they just like pulled them all off yeah
now later what was his name uh not not
[__] eyeballs but the other guy that was
there he says man I saw the whole thing
Man it says that what what exactly
happened because it was badass man
how it all happened the reason why he
attacked her is because I had rung his
Bell so badly he thought that she was me
he thought he was fighting me yeah okay
gave him some false confidence he
thought he was winning there was not
that there was no winner in that boy
it was like fighting a cardboard cutout
of a man there wasn't any strength to
him
just Dave is here and he says that guy
is a creepy [__] I know exactly who you
were talking yeah long-haired annoying
douche yeah
yeah and they said he was always in
there doing [__] yeah and he said he
because I was like yeah because I don't
think I think this was after you had
already left Dave because I didn't see
you after yeah he said I left early yeah
but I folded him up pretty good now he
won't be back I don't think if he comes
back just call me I'll fold him up again
because there's some unfinished business
I haven't paid him back for what he did
to her I'm gonna break him well we
looked for him afterwards is still in
the parking lot I was like either you're
gonna kill him or I'm gonna yeah I was
going to work him over some more
but the door guy said no he left yeah
because we went out there and we were
like where is he
they probably won't let him back in but
they get in though because the guys at
the door are [__] they're not
thinking and they go oh they forget that
that guy's not supposed to be here they
don't recognize him that kind of you
could though he's not
he's the problem
I could just tell by his toe the tone of
his mannerisms I wasn't sure like I
didn't know if he was like really really
drunk or like high as balls or like
boats drunk as a [__] I don't
act like that well I know that but I'm
just saying it's I don't know what the
[__] no he had one warning I said it
will set him back a few feet and he came
back of me trying to be friends I
clocked him pow bottom line I don't
negotiate like some people are just
that's what I mean I just kind of feel
like I don't understand why so many
people have such a hard time like look
if I don't want to talk to you or I
don't want you in my face and I tell you
yeah and I'll be polite the first time
yeah you know hey no thanks or hey
please if you keep persistent yeah
that's it I'm gonna hit you yeah
how many times were we on the dance
floor and some dude like is kind of
dancing like closer and closer to you
and you can see it so you you move
yourself you're like okay right you're
just like I migrate a little bit and he
comes with you yeah like no it's like
yeah I moved away from you for a reason
I don't understand you don't understand
Body Language they don't know club
culture I mean I mean I told look
dudes are going to be dudes but you have
to be [__] stylish about your [__] I
mean you have to understand just the
basic etiquette you know I mean and
alcohol doesn't matter I'll be blasted
and I still remember basic etiquette you
don't grab a chick's ass and I think she
wants you to grab her ass I mean that
should be what happens
etiquette 101 right like I said keep
your hands to yourself why is that hard
but it's like a lot of people really
seem to have a hard time with that
concept and I don't understand why yeah
and this ain't Pakistan you know I don't
know I can understand [__] dudes that
don't grow up in a western Society you
know what I mean they're [__] know
how to behave these are Western dudes
man they're supposed to know [__]
better
and I just I feel like it's probably
because they've gotten away with it so
much
that you know what I mean but it's like
I I just hate the way that because I've
had situations too like being in you
know a long time ago like at Eye bar or
something like that where it's just like
you get a dude like just coming up and
like talking and you're just like you
know no bro it's like I got things to do
or I got like and they just keep on and
they keep persisting and finally you're
just like would you just go the [__]
away and then they won't they just stand
there yeah and then they just keep
wanting to talk to you I'm like dude I
don't have to talk to you I don't owe
you anything I've seen dudes [__] in
the past with Jenny From a Distance walk
up
and asked to buy her a drink
and she said no
and the dude's [__] cool about it and
just like oh well thank you and then you
know and then just yeah like I said I'll
be polite unless you come at me like
real creepy or like real aggressive then
we're gonna then I'll it'll go right to
hitting pretty quick right but if you
come up and you're like hey I'd like to
buy your drink or something like that
I'll be like you know no thanks I
already have one or something like that
and they're just like that's cool yeah
then and they go away because I've had
that happen too it's like yes that is
that is the correct thing to do yeah and
you kinda
from my experience you kind of want that
to happen
because that makes your woman feel
desired you know what I mean her ego
it's good for them that's what it is and
the thing is is like
as a guy I'm like yeah of course these
other dudes [__] walking my nice
compliments yeah yeah he's like oh I
like
you look right and yeah
walking right right that's
like I kind of I never get him a lot
further than hanging the [__] around you
see the dude later right yeah yeah yeah
I kind of feel like some do like
especially dudes that are already have
that mindset they're just like oh well
people get offended if you just give
them a compliment or offer but no that's
not what offends me what offends me is
if I say no thank you or or you just
keep persisting after I've made it clear
that I don't want you around anymore
yeah that's when we're gonna have a
problem I'm not offended by you saying
oh I like your hair or oh can I buy you
a drink and I say oh no thank you so oh
you know that's cool and then they walk
away there's nothing wrong with that
yeah I'm not offended by that in the
least it's a basic rule
for you uh young whippersnappers out
there
women really don't need compliments
because they get lots of them from other
dudes you just end and you end up in an
in an army of simps and you're just
another sip if you do that what's a lot
better is if you just
start a conversation or ask a question
if somebody has nothing to do with her
or whether you look it's my favorite
that's a lot better
the weirdest thing you can do yeah it's
a lot yeah just talk about regular [__]
like you know it would be cool if like
if I was single or something like that I
don't really like to be like picked up
or approached or anything but it's like
if you're gonna be like that like if
you're in mannequins for example and
they have like some videos or where it's
like clips of horror movies like if you
came up and just said oh that's from
Martin or whatever it's like did you see
that it's really good and it's like
you've already established that like
you're into like the same kind of [__]
as me so you know it might not I'm
always like music
or you're reconnected over music please
talk about music yeah yeah it's like
it's just it's just such a it's just
such a rookie mistake to just go up and
be like oh you're beautiful you're
pretty man get the [__] out of here all
I'm just saying is but basically all the
dude's saying this is I'd like to [__]
you well yeah I'll [__] you duh yeah you
know my boyfriend well Jesus
just some stupid [__] like that you know
I'm like oh some dude I don't know oh
yeah I wouldn't think so
yeah
[__] the novelty of it
you know I know I'm an old bat and I'm
like and I'm cranky but you know what I
mean
I don't
I don't like that kind of [__] but yeah
it's just
man that was uh that was really
something I'm actually really glad
because I think I did you know obviously
I didn't see it because I'm not outside
my body but I guess like everybody was
freaking out because they said it looked
like when I fell backward
um they thought that I hit my head on
the Dance Floor
which I think I did but not enough to
hurt I think like my what hurt when I
got home was my hand so I don't know if
I fell on it
or like it's it's okay but it just it
started getting really sore last night
and then I was like oh I must have
fallen on that but did it bruise at all
or I don't think so it was just like
here like right through there
and so I don't I don't know how that
happened maybe that was maybe that was
the thumb that I stuck in is like tried
to stick in his eyeball
hahaha
yeah I mean you know John Smith said
what's the old biker saying sometimes
you have to show stupid the door and
sometimes you're the stupid being show
in the door yeah I mean I really hope
that guy does not come back I don't even
know if he remembers like what happened
he probably does not
I mean I'm gonna remind him like yeah if
we see him around
but he shouldn't show up again there's
no way he's down on the ground trying to
beat him up thinking it's me I was like
his nose
or something yeah yeah one of you did
something we didn't see him afterward
but it's like because I was sitting
there and somebody said oh yeah he when
we saw him I saw it just saw him outside
and his nose is all [__] up yeah that
was the first thing I aimed for yeah I
busted him right in his nose as he
walked up to me
but that's you guys were saying you were
like that location of that club is why
yeah yeah it's always you never know
what's going to happen right but you
could get anything you could get anybody
in there we're going tonight is just us
just our crowd yeah that's on the
warehouse like I said you gotta know
where that is on purpose yeah there's no
trouble there you don't get like people
wandering in when only which like I said
I think that's kind of the problem and
we were just talking about this before
too is that some people that like that
we know and stuff like that actually
won't go to mannequins anymore for that
very reason because it's like you'll
fight it's like ooh too many normies
yeah and like I get it you know what I
mean like I was talking to our friend
earlier and he's just like I don't even
know why you guys still go there it's
just kind of like yeah he's just like
it's just like frat boy blow up doll
party time like there all the time yeah
it's getting more and more like that
yeah and I said as a matter of fact I
only just found out because I saw it on
Facebook but um yeah tonight they're
having a blow up doll dance party bring
your own blow up doll and get a free
drink
so I'm sure that's I'm sure that's gonna
go well
I didn't know exactly what he was
talking what kind of music do you play
for a blow up doll that yeah I don't
know sad like I said Saturday nights
Friday nights
is
um you know more goth industrial like he
plays like what do you play last night
he played like a bunch of old like goth
and 80s stuff like you like the
character in Depeche Mode and Peter
Murphy and stuff like that and then he
did like some like he did played like
aesthetic Perfection and yeah that kind
of stuff and then
um
right yeah he did a lot of that and um
which he usually does he usually does on
uh Fridays Saturdays like he'll play a
little bit of that and then he'll play
some 80s but then he'll just play like a
bunch of random [__] like he'll play
Let's like I'm gonna do a disco set now
I'm gonna do some 90s hip-hop I'm gonna
do so it's just kind of like they used
to call it what the [__] Saturdays but I
don't think they call it that anymore
but it's just pretty much like
everything you know what I mean Super
Fern to Sophie uh hey Trey what's up uh
I made it oh wow hey Sophie I lived near
her for about two years another one that
like there's a few of you that I'm
friends with on Facebook
yeah because he's in Michigan
yeah and he's like you guys ate or
something yeah yeah because he like we
always like uh talk about music and
stuff because he has all the same music
yeah so
you survived the ice storm because
that's what I left like it was and down
here is your power outages and
she came down here and it was like 85
degrees and we just found out that the
air conditioning in my car is not
working
yeah
what was that thing called again
what's that part called the okay the air
something something yeah
it's a little module it's a little
module that plugs in you got to bolt it
in behind the damn
um dashboard cover yeah another
dashboard we called the glove box go in
there
and it um
it makes all the switches work to mix
hot and it just blows hot no matter what
setting it's on yeah it's like the
heat's on yeah you can't even you put it
on vet it'd be cold outside you're gonna
get hot air so somebody's not switching
it's not changing it's just staying on
hot but I hear the uh AC compressor
kicking on
it sounds like it does yeah you put it
on AC but hot air doesn't blow
something's confused in there it blew a
little bit of cold or it wasn't cold it
was just kind of cool it was ambient
temperature it's having a hard time
mixing the two temperatures of air yeah
what the [__] is that thing called we
were just like yeah
and something door or something
second it was the secondary air door
mixer
it's only a 20 part that's a technical
term
Trey said I'll be up there for the
Sisters show in June and probably the
Cure later in the year I'll be in
Detroit multiple times everybody is holy
crap I just saw a thing like Psychedelic
Furs are coming too
not my show
yeah go ahead
Tom wants to be lazy in the back
then you can be
this saturday see what
all right yeah okay
uh let's see Hugo says hey Tom offer
Sophie something you drink no I'm a
Mormon remember
just kidding I'm not but I don't drink
alcohol or caffeine so yes I'm a Mormon
she has what she has water I have water
yeah she has water down there oh
[Laughter]
injured woman you seething back there
wanting to murder some guy and I'm like
okay I'll get you home
it was kind of funny I mean at least
because I had pretty well sobered up by
that point like more or less because you
know
uh hitting the floor will do that to you
but I'll try to stop it there wasn't
enough time I know well like I said I
don't but if I didn't even know what the
[__] was going on for a second yeah I
was yeah I just they pulled him off of
me and [__] I was like where's Jen
and I was like who's that the little
floor and I said is that that dude
who's underneath that dude and I
realized it was you well her wig like he
knocked her wig off like all the way
across the floor yeah yeah so there was
that I had to go find it I was like move
out the way we gotta find the week yeah
yeah I was just kind of like I was like
wow that's kind of like one that's like
one of those [__] uh trashy ass like
Tick Tock reels or something like that
where you just get like snatching
people's wigs off it was like a fear you
had too like well the weird thing about
it last night when I was getting ready
because I couldn't decide like I did my
hair and I was like do I even want to
[__] with my real hair or should I just
put a wig on it to say [__] it and then
I put the wig on and I was like I don't
know like do I really want to wear a wig
I was like and then I had a weird thing
about like what if it comes like what if
I get like gets pulled up which is dumb
because I wear wigs out all the time and
I don't usually think about it
but for some reason like it occurred to
me but then I was like [__] it I don't
feel like doing anything with my real
hair so I just like slapped a wig on and
then that happened
I mean look at what's gonna happen to
the hair that's like that well I mean
usually you got it on yeah you have it
all you have a whole like this song how
bad did it look I was like at least my
hair looked kind of normal like
underneath you were bald or like yeah
like I did like it wasn't like all
[__] up looking or greasy or you know
it was it's just was black you know what
I mean but and it was just black and
down and it was clean too which is not
usually but so those two little com that
encounters those two fights had last
night were the first two fights that I
had sense enhancement HRT enhancement
and all that training
game probably about 30 40 pounds of
muscle over years lost all that weight
and [__]
and I gotta tell you
there's no comparison and I was on 400
Megs of [__] test and coming off of a
trend cycle
and I've been doing Master on and all
kinds of other stuff which [__]
increases like your muscle density and
[__]
no mortal man
no mortal man that is not on training
because it is not training could ever
could ever stand that's why I'm like I
pity the fool that like no tried to push
you to like push your buttons twice like
oh yeah that dude
the only way you could ever match that
person match a person on that [__] or on
gear and [__] at my level of
development is that you'd have to be a
trade fighter like an MMA type guy
or you'd have to have a lot of mass
you'd have to be you know six four six
two and a decent weight 240 you know but
still I'd probably wear that guy out
because that first one was probably
about six one and it was like a
cardboard cutout there's just
I grabbed his neck and it was just like
mush
because just there's no
so much fat content in these guys I mean
they're like 30 percent fat
just like the hamburger at the
supermarket
I'm 13
there's a big difference
of being nearly 200 pounds and only 13
fat that's about like what a leopard is
[Laughter]
that's why I don't want them in sports
because it would it's just not fair
that's not fair it was like beating up
children
and not an ounce of fear loved it loved
every bit of it wanted to kill him yeah
that's why I was like um if she didn't
leave after that we would have ended up
like a police
have gotten probably because I was
pretty mad too
no no no no
all right and I had alcohol in my system
but it didn't even matter
didn't even matter
still about as twice as fast as them
and twice the strength at least at least
literally it was like beating up a card
cardboard cutout made out of marshmallow
or something
don't get so [__] up like the little
guides where you're picking a fight with
people you can't you can't mess with
like what are you saying no big little
dude I'm just saying like he was so
[__] up that like he's gonna pick a
fight with you like how delusional do
you have to be he was better than me
though
not maybe in height but he was skinny he
wasn't he had no muscle on him didn't
matter these guys don't know anything
they can't look at a person and judge
anything they don't know anything you
know I grew up in a horse industry I can
look at a horse and tell you exactly
what that horse is going to do just
based on his [__] how much weights on
his definition and [__] that's kind of
the way I look at dudes I can size them
up interesting they can't size anything
up is if their eyeballs are higher than
yours up off the ground they think they
can beat you no you got to look at my
stat and my specs dude [__]
yeah you know I [__] weighed 20
pounds more than you and it's all muscle
on a shorter [__] frame with a lot
more leverage
and just a lot more density
you're kind of crazy yo that's just
parts
you're sweating sweaty
everyone's going man
he kept doing it no you didn't smell
like a girl I said Pizza I say you smell
like an old Onion Pizza an onion pizza I
said stale I said well no I said I said
you smell like an old onion pieces I'm
sitting around for a while but still
edible that's what I said well less
edible as the night goes on probably
well yeah that's what I'm saying
I was like still I'd still eat it but
you know what I mean you did kind of
smell like good but there's worse things
you could smell it
because I think when you're on that
other stuff he smelled like really
strange yeah let me come back and have
sex
[Laughter]
tearing it up we would have we were up
until like four in the morning and it
never ended and then he tried getting
tired and then he tried to wake me up
again at seven and I was like dude and
like he forgot to close the blinds too
so it was like super bright in there I'm
like me it's like I only got three hours
of sleep and I only got like five hours
of sleep the night before and we'd been
out like all because I'd worked all day
and then we went out and I was just like
I am [__] tired man and so finally I
was just like I have to go back to sleep
and then I slept till like almost 11
which is super super late for me hardly
ever so I was like yeah that's awesome
because I knew we were going out tonight
too so yeah I was like I got I'm not
gonna drink that much tonight though
because Barbarella they just have those
kind of like little like [__] gin
and tonic in a can white claw type
things yeah and I usually just drink one
of those and then I'm like and then I
just get a bottle of water and then just
refill it from the water machine like at
Barbarella so that's what I do from
there I don't I don't usually go there
and like drink a lot
um wait we're uh someone sent you money
yeah I know thank you very much Jeffy
art for the super chat with the little
good job quick little thing there
glasses over there Zach says Tom wants
to have his boob Harem on both sides yes
that's probably yeah Steve Zach knows uh
Trey said based on what I know of Tom
from the show he's one of the last
people on Earth I'd pick a fight with
insane something yeah yeah I mean you'd
have to be like really really clueless
like I said even if you didn't know you
like people that know you know better
but I'm just saying it's like even if
people that didn't know you I mean
clearly you look
terrifying are you ready to beat someone
and like I said you're also kind of a
crazy person yeah and you would I I feel
like that's what kind of scares me a
little bit because I kind of feel like
you know if we're out drinking and stuff
and somebody does something really
[__] up and I get it because I feel
like this too but it's like you would
probably just keep going until you
killed the person yeah if nobody
I was like I said I was gonna break that
bottle over his head and then use that
stump to start grinding and cutting
pieces of his face off because I already
had him in a that was just what was
coming to mind it says I'm gonna cut his
nose off
but and I don't know if the bottle would
have done it but it would you might have
to saw it yeah I was thinking I was
gonna scrape that [__] off like somehow
he's gonna scrape his teeth yeah so he
looks like a skeleton face
yeah and what's her name what's the
little biker girl's name Anna it's Anna
yeah
yeah we've known her forever she's
trying to talk me down
yeah I was too I was just like please
don't like don't get us kicked out or
like don't like start a big thing we
need to get home tonight yeah that's I
was like I don't want to go to jail I
may have let him go
but then the next thing you'd know he's
beating you up because he thinks he's
fighting you he thinks he's fighting me
yeah so I know I was I had I had it
right I should have just sit there and
just ground big pieces of his face off
[__] that would have been that was
that was actually the path to Victory
there
you'd have been in no shape after that
well yeah like I said it's like a paint
scraper
[Laughter]
just peel it up like peeling off an
orange field it would be like bloody and
I don't know we heard last time and I
don't think I told you this but um did
Dave tell me this like the last time we
wrote mannequins that like somebody took
a [__] on the dance floor yeah yeah
that's so weird I don't know I don't
know said no no the bartender said she's
like I think that's an urban legend she
said I think somebody just set off a
stink bomb yeah okay but she's like I
think what happened is she's like
because it smelled really bad we all had
to like get out of here and everything
like that but she's like I think maybe
over time like it evolved into like
somebody
I don't think somebody actually squatted
and took a [__] on the Dance Floor I
think that maybe like you know how
sometimes people that are um because you
said oh people are on heroin and stuff
like sometimes like a little turtle like
just kind of like Escape it's just kind
of like good on your pale leg and um so
we were I was thinking maybe that's what
happened and then it's like then people
then it gets like spread around but I
don't know if that's what happened or
not because the bartender she she's like
I was here she's like I think it's like
somebody set off a stink bomb I don't
think somebody like [__] on the dance
floor and I guess she would know
that would be absolutely terrible
everyone's in their shoes just like
I would I would not I I would still be
throwing up now like if that had
happened because I'm even thinking about
it you bring your nice goth boots home
and they've got someone else's [__] like
right it's like I was even thinking
about it and that I was telling you a
story like a long time ago about how I
was in a grocery store and there was
this like old man like in baggy pants in
front of me like in the produce section
like a turd like came out the bottom of
it and I was just like and I was telling
you that story and I was gagging
thinking about it yeah so just thinking
about it so maybe maybe I should stop
talking about what would make it worse
is it hits the floor rolls a little bit
and then I don't know the size comes
around and lands on
all right I'm gonna heave to like okay
seriously I mean I'm not gonna hear you
but I'll guess you watch all these
movies
okay that's and I think I brought this
up before horror movies I can watch the
Gory of [__] and it's like you know cut
people's heads off peel their skin off
it's just like it's fine I'm like oh
that's Entertainment you start doing
[__] about [__] or vomit no thanks I'm
out I can't watch I mean I watched Human
Centipede but I kind of watched it like
that
because I was like oh this is too gross
it's too gross like it's an even P I'm
not rolled down and with like bodily
fluids pee is like the least threatening
though yeah I can kind of get but it the
second you start doing stuff with like
poop or vomit
like you know because there's some
scenes it wasn't there that scene in um
[__] man audition where they were like
drinking from Boulevard but it's like
yeah no thanks no no I I couldn't watch
that part
I couldn't watch that part but it's like
I can watch gory [__] all day long like
I said you can rip out people's hearts
you when it doesn't bother me in the
slightest but the second somebody starts
really all they have to do is like talk
about poop
like you know and then I start imagining
it and then I'll start like gagging you
never had kids then because I know well
that might be one of the big reasons I
don't know if that's the main reason but
um but for sure that was that was up
there in the top 10 right because you
won't avoid poop that's what I mean it's
just gonna it's just like a poop parade
like day in and day out so I'm I mean I
have a cat and that's she's kind of
gross too she's yeah she's kind of she's
not gross
getting stinky again well yeah
yeah that's so gross yeah glad reaction
although I think she's okay I mean today
like the last couple days like her
husband's stinky but it was like really
stinky she had to get like her anal
there was one time she just walked by
you and
yeah but like she you she would just
walk by and you'd smell it yeah and I
was just like oh my God
and now go you stick and I'd like sniff
towards her butt like and she's looking
at like how dare you
yeah like Christopher Walker like
Christopher Walken in communion how dare
you
this is Christopher Walken [__]
classic man that was one of the highest
of his career was having that that hose
I've never seen the movie but I've
listened it was terrible but you've
mentioned it on so many shows I feel
like it's in Green in my head I've never
even seen it
thinking about that scene will never not
make me laugh I mean that [__] it's just
like the you know what I and I think
I've said this before but like the whole
thing with like Christopher Walken be
like how dare you like it and it seemed
like so over dramatic and yet under
dramatic like in regards to the
situation like he's on an alien ship and
they're putting a vacuum tube like up
his ass and it's just like the way he
reacted was like really funny but I
think what made that scene much funnier
for me was the fact that the aliens had
the anal vacuum cleaner just like in the
wall handy dandy like so they could just
like pull it out of the wall and like
stick it up and I'm just like wow that's
convenient and I just I don't know why
that was so funny to me like that was
the funniest part of that scene to me
that the aliens just had that right
there just for such occasions and I was
like well yeah I guess if you were in
anal probing alien race
then you would have these little
conveniences in your spacecraft
like
just right at the ready
I don't know why that's so funny to me
but it is
uh Trey says about you he just has a
don't [__] with me look about him yeah
um a lot of guys can't they can't
compute that because I'm only five six
so they they have guys who are 5 10 and
11 and they think because their eyes are
above mind if we look at each other
that they've automatically won the fight
and that's not what it is man because
I'll just take you apart like a man
takes a kite apart
if you're not in training
on [__] anabolics and like sub
[__] 15 body fat and if you're not
[__] jacked you're not gonna really
have to stand a chance unless you're a
heavyweight and if you're especially if
you're not trade now if you're [__]
guided into MMA your trade fighter if
you're natural even though a lot of
those guys aren't natural I don't think
any of those guys are I don't think any
athletes especially pro athletes they're
not natural they're just not on [__]
when they're [__] play in the game in
training they're on all kinds of [__]
that's how they get those size
but uh
no like I said no mortal man really
stands a chance especially if he's
untrained if he's not lifting weights if
he's not
a trained fighter you just don't have
you just don't stand a chance I just
[__] go right to you
and if you're big it's just gonna I'm
just going to use a different route to
do it
you ever seen in [__] paintings for
Zetta paintings a Conan jumping on a
damn giant with a dagger and you look at
him as kind of like the size difference
it's like a child fighting an adult I
can handle that I could do that
I know I can do that because
your [__] the chemicals that are in
you and the hormones and [__] you're a
kamikaze it'd be like
a 60 pound Bobcat can [__] [__]
grown man up it's gonna be like that
you know
John Smith said so no Pink Flamingos for
you then I have seen Pink Flamingos but
yeah that scene I was just like like the
whole time like through it I felt like
because I loved John Waters so it's like
I felt like I had to watch it but um and
it's really good but yeah that scene was
like I was I had a hard time you know
what I mean I'll just I can do it it's
just I'll gag all the way through it and
then when I think about it later I'll
gag for a long time
Zach says apropos of nothing but I could
use some grooming advice my hair is thin
wavy and got a ton of cowlicks how do I
make it not look like A Rat's Nest shave
it off yeah easy
Trey says damn I'm six foot three I
would Tower over Tom I'm skinny as [__]
though he says
the thing is you're fighting a taller
guy and that's why on that first one I
just went in so close out of it slapped
him all right
a taller guy has reach on you and if
he's if if you if you if you
have The Misfortune of running into a
guy who's a trained fighter he's going
to try to [__] stay back and sling
good fists sling his fist at you and if
he's making good connections with your
head he'll knock you out
but he can only do that from afar you're
going to get right up on him
that way he can't get a real powerful
blow on you he's just going to be doing
body blows
and you have to take that fight to the
ground
that'd be the best way
uh but but you can just there's no plan
no plan survives the fight first time
you get punched in the face or you're
punching somebody else in the face all
the plants go out the window you just
it's like dancing If You Can Dance real
well
you could fight it's very similar like
and I didn't plan anything of what I did
to that dude and it was like fighting a
child
and I guarantee you that dude couldn't
dance
well mostly what he did was lurk
creepily so yeah imagining probably not
no that's the other thing like we were
dancing he wasn't dancing he was kind of
like walking through the like you know I
got I got yeah it's like Jesus Christ
Don't We Know No Parking On The Dance
Floor for one thing like don't just go
there and stand there and talk or like
stand there and look at your phone and
like step people trying to dance move it
but it's like also don't walk through
like what are you doing knock it off
people that dance really well have very
good Mind Body Connection
the connection between their mind and
their body is very good they're not
thinking about dancing they're just
dancing and it looks great none of that
[__] is planned It's Just Happening
that's the same thing with fighting it's
just
you're
you're not even thinking about it it's
all just unfolding and you're doing the
right things and hopefully the other
guy's doing the doing wrong things and
then you end up winning
but it's very similar
to dadson
and if you're on gear you're so much
faster than other people
and I didn't get hit I didn't even get a
scratch on me
uh but if I did it wouldn't have made
much difference because I'm on stuff
that makes that are anti-inflammatories
so it's you'd never really get any brain
swelling head injuries are really
diminished
it's harder to knock somebody out when
they're on steroids
because it just is that's why they take
them
we got another Super Chat thank you very
much Aaron no real comment here's my
monthly tip for all the great shows well
thank you very much thank you very much
we really do appreciate it Winterfell
forever said uh yeah I was on a train
once and a woman just Squat and pissed
her life away almost in front of me she
was totally trashed of course okay not
the greatest experience
yeah I mean you know
we've seen [__] like that like after the
clubs have closed and things like that I
saw some [__] like that in Korea one
time walking down walking down [__]
Street on hooker Hill on it Taiwan and
some old lady [__] squatted over a
grill and just started pissing couldn't
see anything because she had that damn
moo moo on like
he was kissing down in a grill well hey
that's a good place in the gutter at
least you didn't just pee on the side of
a wall like a dude would yeah
[Laughter]
those little
little [__] wheeled baskets that you
put shopping and you Trail it behind you
what do you call it like a car like a
wheeled cart yeah does it have a name I
don't even think those things have a
name
but she had one of those and had her
groceries in it and she's sitting there
pissing looking around just smiling
because who's gonna say anything to a
little lady and they do that in Korea so
they did back in the day it's like hey
gotta pay you don't have time to find a
bathroom I don't have time for this
nonsense she probably can't hold it
she's old yeah that's what I'm saying I
think they just did that in Old Korea
the whole the world's your toilet
I guess
Jen says how's the new job going it's
pretty good it's pretty good it's you
know pretty low-key I think like the
main it's just the commute is kind of a
pain in the ass but other than that it's
fine
Trey said actually I saw a woman do that
in Detroit once my girlfriend started
yelling at her about it too it was in
Auburn Hills that's not that far like
yeah
it's not no it's not like trashy like
Pontiac next to Auburn Hills and that's
a little sketchy but Auburn Hills no one
should be pissing
I kind of feel like I've never seen this
happen in real life but you kind of see
um I remember this one picture that I
saw one time this really really drunk
girl and she'd fallen asleep like in
someone's yard and it like [__] herself
yeah so there was that I was like wow I
bet she was like really
embarrassed the next morning and like a
you know picture was all over the
Internet so I'm sure that was great
so we're gonna do like drunk [__] up
[__] like that make sure nobody takes a
picture of you and post it online
to so people make a meme about now
everyone has their phone out so you're
doing anything like that you're probably
gonna end up online I know I figure well
it occurred to me this morning I was
like I wonder if anybody filmed that
[__] last night because there was a
bunch of
people there
yeah what if you're gonna be like oh man
go viral oh man after the [__] I asked
you said I look good well we'll be ill I
said did I look good my form okay well I
I wanted to see because I wanted to see
it like what happened exactly because
like I said I wasn't like involved in
the first part of it and like all of a
sudden so I really wanted to see like
what happened here's the thing that one
I didn't think was gonna go sideways
like that because like I said the dude
that was involved yeah when I pushed him
back any normal person I think it would
just go that's it yeah that's it because
he what he didn't look like the kind of
guy that would question my decision but
I think he was not all with it and
that's why yeah like he questioned it
because he was so inebriated yeah I mean
yeah he seemed like
senior stick says isn't sidetracks on
Friday usually it is yeah but um we went
to mannequins last night and I worked
all day and we didn't have time to do
the show so I announced earlier
well I think we said on the
Regular Show on Wednesday that we were
moving it to Saturday just because it's
easier
it was easier for us because I was like
worn out you know what I mean give her a
break that's like three if you go out
that's like a whole day of work a show
and going out every Friday that'd be
rough yeah yeah I mean we don't go out
every Friday but
um you know we usually go out like once
or twice a month
but I can do it it's like honestly I was
kind of impressed with myself last night
because I was still awake at 4 00 am and
I had been up since a little before 5am
so we were almost for 24 hours yeah and
I said I was up all day yeah and well
you yeah you don't usually but you woke
up the same time as me yeah so I worked
all day drove you know drove an hour
there an hour back and then came here
ate dinner got ready and then we went
out and then got beat up by a random
dude and uh you know then came home and
we watched Dan Bell and ate some snacks
and
fell asleep at like four in the morning
and then Tom tried to wake me up at
seven o'clock in the morning again yeah
grabbing my boob yeah and I was like
yeah
please I was like and please get up and
close the blinds I can't sleep he
doesn't care like it he can sleep in the
middle of the day that's what I've known
asleep in the lights I can't oh just
snap it one just snap at six I can't do
that I can't do that I would like to I'd
like to be able to sleep in the daytime
but one it's too bright it's too hot and
if I sleep during the day I always wake
up feeling like really weird and like
groggy
I don't know I don't really like that
feeling I don't feel like refreshed or
anything I always wake up and be like I
feel like kind of [__] up like like my
schedule's all messed up so usually I'll
just stay awake even if I'm really tired
and then I'll just go to bed like a
little early like it's like oh I'll try
to go to bed at 9 30 or 10 or whatever
and uh you know but yeah last night it's
weird because I was tired but I kind of
got my second wind you know so I wasn't
feeling really really tired
and even then like I at whatever time it
was like 3 34 in the morning we finally
like laid down
I was just it took me like a little
while to fall asleep too I guess because
I was thinking about like the fight and
everything and then I think that's when
it occurred to me that it's like oh I
wonder if anybody filmed it like with
their phone it happened so fast though
like yeah I don't know if anybody really
had to I don't even think most people
knew what was going on because it just
like it kind of looked like a pile
because everyone jumped on them and it
was like a bunch of people in this
corner and then you and then everyone
was worried about you and it just
it wasn't that easy to get yeah it was
just weird I mean
the one thing and some of the people
that were like coming over and because
like some of them I've seen them before
but I don't really know them that well
but but that was kind of cool that like
everybody just like hurted me like
carefully I was like seriously I'm like
I'm fine I'm seriously I'm fine did you
hit your head and you said you kind of
did yeah I kind of did but it didn't
hurt like and my hand didn't hurt until
later like in the car I started noticing
that my hand was really sore so I said
oh maybe I landed on that or maybe I
stuck in his face or something I don't
really know but um but yeah so everybody
was like really can we buy you a drink
do you want some water it's like it's
just like dude I'm fine I just you know
I said I didn't really know what
happened it was just I said I'm just
more surprised than anything because it
just like didn't expect things to go
that way you know what I'm saying that's
that's all uh Mrs Evans already party
said I stay with my aunt in Nola when I
was 14 and learned all about why the
businesses hose off the sidewalks in the
morning
Trey says I can't sleep in a room with
an open door or the blinds open it's
weird I don't mind the door being open
um because we just usually leave ours
open like the bedroom door but I I can't
sleep because if if the blinds are open
like especially on the weekend I'm
always like please close the blinds
because otherwise I will wake up as soon
as the sun comes up the if you want to
put me to sleep quick put me outside
with a rucksack and a uniform on some
kind of military Airfield where you have
[__] jet turbines going I will
[__] go to sleep instantly I love it
I love the sound of [__] jet turbines
you need like maybe you know like they
do those like they make white noise
channels maybe there's like a jet
tournament Channel you just I'm sure
there's got like a loop two hours yeah
it's like it's it's like a white noise I
just [__] love it and it's like it's
associated with such good memories of
being like with your friends in in
different places of the world you know
what I mean loading the Choppers up
waiting for the Choppers to come and
just [__] like that you know I just
[__] love it
I mean I and another thing too is that
you can sleep because you always like to
have your uh earbuds in yeah I have to
have noise and you have to have noise
and I do not like having noise I can't
sleep like it's really the slightest
noise will wake me up like I'll hear
Pookie scratching and be like what was
that you know what I mean so I like to
have quiet like but I have um I have
like a column fan like on the what do
you call that thing that's next to your
bed the nightstand yeah that's it and um
that kind of makes just like a fan noise
and that's nice but other than that I
don't I don't like any kind of noise
yeah I don't like it now if I'm really
tired I can fall asleep like if I'm
watching a show or like music like quiet
classical music or something like that
like yeah that's good but like a lot of
talking or like something you could be
invested in is kind of like yeah I can't
really listen I can't like listen to a
podcast or anything like that because
like a lot of times I'll be either
paying attention to that or it's too
distracting you know what I mean yeah
because in my early development you know
in the Infantry and Airborne units and
stuff noise is always associated with
safety silence is always associated with
Danger
because I get that but see I like it to
I like it to be quiet because then
silent but yeah well I like it to be
quiet because then it's like oh what if
you know Pookie needs something in the
night or what if you know somebody
breaks it or something like that like I
want to be able to hear if something
goes wrong but you know what I mean and
like I feel like if I was listening to
noise it would drown that out
you know so I guess that's why
John Smith said since turning 40 I count
myself lucky if I sleep six hours a
night though sometimes I'll sleep seven
to eight and it feels like a tease yes
well now I mean I have noticed that I've
slept a lot less like as I've gotten
older like I'm still tired but I kind of
feel like
I don't know I was telling Tom last
night I was like I'm just kind of used
to being kind of tired like all the time
you know what I mean in a man it's a
sign of low test
Sergeant injecting it's at your age you
need to be on test anyway sleep like a
baby
you eat and then you want to be like a
lion and just lay around
you want to [__] go do some [__]
with your belly in the Sun
and then looking at
it just like a lion it's exactly like
that watching the females do all the
work
it's kind of like injecting morphine and
sex into your veins
and love
he had become big friendly lion
yeah lions are super friendly oh lions
are very friendly
watch them they're very friendly
just like a really big kitty like yeah
they're they're friendly
if you raise them from yeah yeah
are baby lions still called kitten no I
guess they're called Cubs I think duh
unless they're different when they're
their animals have like stages where
it's like their newborn and then they're
young or something yeah Trey says I have
to sleep with a fan running too
yeah I mean I got the fan it's not so I
like the the noise that it makes it's
like but I got it mostly because for
whatever reason like it's kind of Stuffy
in that room which is weird because the
office is usually like freezing cold
but the bedroom is for some reason kind
of warm
and so I always have to have like air
blowing on me because I can't stand
being [__] warm I hate it Zach said I
slept so good last night I woke up
drooling
I said also I like Sophie's necklace
thank you yeah it is cool isn't it I
threw it on real quick because like
we're not totally ready to go out but
yeah it's like yeah Jenny was like just
do your face like be like mostly ready
yeah because then we don't because we
don't really we don't have to leave for
like an hour and a half it's only 7 30
and we don't have to leave till nine it
doesn't even open until 9 30. so we
probably should shut the show down in
about a half hour though yeah we
probably yeah yeah because then we have
an hour to like get outfits right and
[__] like that
but like it's a lot more low-key because
it takes a while for everybody to get
there and although we haven't been on a
Saturday night in a while yeah it's been
a few months since we've been on a
Saturday and this is like our crowd we
know all these people we've known most
of these people for [__] long long
you know 10 years at least
that's who's going to be there where
we're going tonight yeah so hopefully
yeah that's like that's like our peeps
it won't be a bunch of random ass
there's always there's always people you
know they bring guests you know people
you've never seen before but the core
audience is all people we know
the core client tells people we know see
but that I mean I don't know I was just
saying
I was telling our friend Dimitri about
like the [__] that happened at
mannequins last night I said this is why
you don't you don't allow normies to
like walk around unsupervised in
Civilization because oh stop it
they can't be trusted to behave they
don't know how to behave who do we need
the rules like posted on the wall like
school like rules of the dance floor
they probably can't read you never know
what's going to happen or who's gonna go
in there and there's just people of all
kinds and some dudes are just especially
today even though Florida's a I think a
good place to be a guy
um there's guys today that just don't
have a lot of [__] experience with
with women and how to behave inside
clubs around women they just they saw it
on television you know
and then some of the other places you
know I mean are just filled with people
that are like that so they saw the Woos
so they show up with bad attitudes you
know
and you can tell the second they walk in
the door you can tell who's gonna be
trouble yeah
[Laughter]
well like
subculture-based clubs are not like that
at all
they'll show some [__] like that in the
movie but they portray it in the [__]
erroneously yeah that's not what it is
the word bad people are no they're not
like that either that's a hilarious I
feel like they did that a lot in the 80s
like whenever like they had like the the
you know kind of Yuppie protagonist and
he's like oh I'm gonna go to like the
Seedy part of town yeah and then you go
to like some punk rock bar and everyone
was like an [__] and they were all
like rude and spitting at him and stuff
I'm like that's not how that works no
real friendly it wasn't in like schools
of bullies were always like Punk kids
and stuff too and it's like yeah they
were always like the villains I mean it
was it was little the little snotty rich
kids that were the [__] they were
the ones that were picking on us not the
other way around
yeah it was yeah so I kind of feel like
maybe
and I don't know we don't know like what
other kind of clubs these people go to
but maybe that's acceptable there like
maybe that flies like maybe that's how
everyone acts there which is why I
probably never go there and ever in my
life because I don't want to be around
that
that mess
you know but
it's kind of a different it's a
different thing man
subculture
clubs the people if you you go in there
that's a scene those people all know
each other you can't really just come in
as a stranger and try to throw your
weight around
you might as well just try to join a
cult and start at the top it doesn't
work that way it's going to take years
of you being in there looking the right
way doing the right things and meeting
the right people and to work your way up
in into that scene a lot of the guys
will start there because they like in
the god scenes because they like golf
girls who wouldn't they got
depending on what year it is you know so
sometimes the good ones go and replace
by bad ones but then good ones come back
sometimes you know it's a good one yeah
it depends on where you are some scenes
it's nothing but fat girls you know or
fat guys or High girls and [__] real
doggy dudes didn't you say Michigan was
kind of like that mission I see I'm not
really in a scene oh but when I go to
shows or the few times I have gone to
clubs it's like I don't know when you
went to a golf club there though well I
went to a show well okay yeah I've been
at the gecko but you get that crowd you
know what I mean and it's just
you know I'll talk to him oh find some
people you don't understand like yes
I live there they're probably really
nice people but it's not what you think
it is back in the late 80s I was living
in Detroit
I would go to like St Andrews Hall the
shelter City Club later on but that
wasn't opened up until maybe it was open
yeah I guess that was open
um and uh man it's hotties man [__]
and they were death rock girls at that
time when they were my favorite they
were 10 years older than me when I was
showing up and I was a pipsqueak you
know new to the scene didn't have a
chance first time I saw those [__]
[__] and those damn fish debts and all
ripped it looked like some of a specimen
remember remember that yeah they looked
like that or Alien Sex Fiend or
something man my mind was blown I love
that I was just like oh man I was
listening to Sisters of Mercy and stuff
at that time but I didn't know about
death rock yeah you know even though
it's adjacent yeah I feel like Sisters
of Mercy are kind of even back then were
kind of like a lot more accessible than
you know stuff like bat cave or death
rock or something like that like a lot
of people didn't know about that kind of
[__] and those girls were older than me
that I didn't even stand a chance you
know what I mean but that's where my
Beginnings that's where I started this
was in the time when the [__] if you
watch the movie The Crow that's the
world they're talking about that's
taking place in Detroit in a kind of a
slightly fictionalized Detroit
but that's kind of the way the scene was
a few gram thirsts gave us a uh gave a
super chat it says Michigan in the house
[Laughter]
but uh in the late 80s
Detroit had a fantastic and in the 90s
too I went back and checked it like
around 95 or 94. I went to City Club and
it was still good
um
hotties man a lot of them
I always like my the death Rock
aesthetic is probably my favorite still
like after all this time honestly one of
the best
times I ever had like just in general as
far as like the scene is concerned is
when I went to the drop dead Festival in
New York City this is back in
2018 I went two years in a row
and it was um like a three-day
death rock festival and it was in a club
that was like three stories so like on
the bottom in the basement they had like
DJs and then they had bands like on both
floors so you could go back and forth
and not only were all the bands [__]
amazing like I saw Nina Hagen I saw like
the like all skeletal family I saw like
all these old Cinema strange and they
had like all these really good bands but
they also um everybody that came there
looked fabulous and they and they all
like made their own [__] because death
rock is very DIY still
so cut up fish Dad yeah everybody had
made their own jackets like with all
these pie it's like and they just had
all the big [__] Mohawks
yeah it's like they all look amazing
they all looked amazing and I was like
you know I tried to do good too but I
was just kind of like yeah I was like I
paled in comparison like everybody
looked super yeah for those of you don't
know the motif for the style of what
we're talking about imagine if a vampire
was a punk rocker and a hooker
that's what they look like
I love that I love that
and that's probably I don't know it's
kind of hard for me to say but I think
that's kind of my favorite
Sub sub genre
is probably like I really like that kind
of grungy like post-punk death Rock
stuff like like from the 70s to the
early 80s
like one of my favorite I just got
Spotify because like I said
um you know I have to drive back and
forth like and I was like I need music
and I have you guys my car is so old
that it has a cassette player uh for you
children uh we used to have music on
these little plastic things that had
like tape in them but yeah so my car had
a cassette player and you have to buy
this thing at AutoZone for like 10 bucks
and it's a cassette you put it in there
and then it has like a little cord and
you hook it up to your phone so you can
play is there one Spotify my first car
was like a 90s car too but like I
remember isn't there one you can just
plug the aux cord in though like there
might be that like you could put the aux
cord and the other end plugs into your
phone maybe yeah but that yeah that's um
I think there's one you can hook into
the cigarette later too but I think the
cigarette later in my car does not work
so that's why we're gonna get rid of
that car soon well I mean don't tell her
that because then don't let the car hear
you because eventually she's gonna start
dumping more problems yeah
oh you want the AC okay what else can we
bring right that's what I'm saying it's
like now it's just gonna be like I'm
always just like don't jinx I always try
to talk nice to the car when I'm in
there because you know like what if now
that I'm doing that big long drive and
everything I'm just like come on baby
you're my favorite let's see you know
what I mean but yeah so I got um where
was I going with that okay yeah I got
Spotify and honestly my favorite because
you know how they do like the little
um you know little playlist yeah
yeah they have a little playlist thing
and my favorite thing that I found so
far was that I went because you guys
know I love uh the birthday party which
was Nick Cave's old band and so they
have like a whole playlist of them but
then they have another one that's called
the birthday party radio which plays
some of their songs but also Associated
bands or bands that are kind of like
them you can you can click any song or
any artist like if there's always a
button whatever it is and you can make a
radio station off anything yeah that's
what I'm saying so it's like that has
been my favorite so far
um because it plays a lot of birds day
party obviously but it also plays like
crime in the city solution or something
like these Immortal Souls I think there
was some einsters that are noibatin on
there
um and just like but they're choosing
the Banshees and like all this other
creatures and stuff so I really really
liked the mix of that you know like the
early alternative one is good too
because that was kind of like that had
like Lou Reed and David Bowie and
Bauhaus and you gotta get to make your
own playlist yeah well I yeah I went
through and like I picked a bunch of
bands but I haven't really had time yeah
I know it took you waste a lot of time
on there just making playlists and doing
stuff Trey says 45 Grave yeah they're
awesome I love 45 Brave I love 40 Fair
grave yeah they're actually one of one
of the bands that I put on there they're
like they were La death Rock
because I kind of feel like well in
England they called it bat cave because
that was the name of the club where like
specimen played in Alien Sex being
played and stuff like that so they
called the genre Batcave for a while so
I kind of feel like death Rock was maybe
I can't really remember like I kind of
remember this happening but it was I was
not that old but I kind of think the
term death Rock was maybe more applied
to the LA scene was like Christian death
and 45 Grave and stuff but
I don't know now I think it's just kind
of because I feel like in the early to
mid 2000s I feel like death Rock had
kind of a little bit of a Resurgence
that was when the drop dead Festival was
going on
as I think they moved it to Europe later
on but they had it in the U.S they had
in California that they had it in New
York in two years but you know there was
and there was a lot of like newer death
rock kind of bands coming out like I
said like Cinema strange came out in the
early 2000s and yeah like bloody dead
and sexy and uh you know bands like that
so
Frank the Baptist
stuff like that which we're all like
really really good that sounded a lot
like stuff from like the old days
Trey says that first Christian death LP
is a [__] landmark in death rock it
is indeed it is Christian death are
awesome I saw them live once but that
was after I think
I want to say it was after rods Williams
died what year did he die that was uh 98
oh yeah it was definitely I think it was
98.
well wait when did I see them though do
you want me to just Google it
whenever I like listen to your shows and
there's these moments I'm always just
like let me help you
I have my phone
I know it's like if I wasn't stupid I
would probably just like because my
phone's just right over there I could
probably just bring it over and like
Google stuff when I needed to he he did
die in 1998 April April 1st April Fool's
Day yeah yeah I remember it was April
Fool's Day but I couldn't remember like
what year it was commit suicide hung
himself
but I just when did I I can't remember
when I saw that it was me and my brother
and somebody else and we went to I think
it was at Visage or the edge or one of
the places in Orlando that's not there
anymore you know Javier yeah he was
dating him okay you told me that yeah
like at the time that he died before Oh
okay holy [__] yeah that's [__] up
yeah Roz Williams says bye
yeah preferred women though
but a friend of mine was a real good
looking goth guy he's a famous pretty
famous DJ right now I'm gonna call him
Elijah said his name is Javier
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna call him out
even though I just said his name he goes
by his DJ name on that yeah yeah yeah
he's got a boyfriend he's basically
married now so that's all that was all
ancient history
but uh no he he was let's just say he
was hanging out with Roz
for a while there I felt bad for a run
yeah heroin got him and it just [__]
up his career and he killed himself over
it he was great man he was like the
gothic David Bowie he sounded just like
Dave Bowie to me
David like David Bowie with a much
harder Edge kind of sinister sounded
really good lyrics
real good lyrics yeah
um
but your time to Mom was good too when
she got into Christian death they did
some stuff together
I even kind of begrudgingly grudgingly
started to like Valor some Valor stuff
it's just that
man when I associate
I associate Ross Williams voice with
Christian death you know well yeah I
mean I think I had some of that Valor
albums too but it's just kind of like I
don't know we were kind of mad about it
at the time yeah but we were kind of mad
about it God damn it you're not Roz yeah
knock it off I wouldn't say on the
outside who was singing you had to take
a chance and just buy the album you go
oh it's [__] Roz
yeah you're like ah you mean it's
Valeria or yeah Valerie yeah yeah John
Smith said speaking of punk is anyone
else amazed at the cramps getting
mainstream success thanks to Wednesday
yeah I um I didn't watch the show like
until a little bit after but my sister
had already told me she's like oh
there's a cramp song in there you're
gonna really dig it and um so I already
knew like what was coming but at that
point like I'd already been at
mannequins one night and he had played
gugumuk and I was just kind of like oh
awesome because like he plays the cramp
sometimes like not usually that song but
he usually plays other ones and so I was
just like oh awesome so I didn't think
anything about it but then like once I
watched the show I was like oh that's
why that's also why he started playing
running up that hill all the time
because it was on stranger things and I
was just kind of like now I'm like
conflicted because I'm like well [__] I
really I love this song but it's like
I've known this song since the 80s and
it's like now it's gonna look like oh I
know it gets a stranger things I'm just
like no ah and it's like these are the
problems that we all those songs if you
go on like YouTube or something the
comments are always like who is here
before or whatever yeah
you know I know it's like I seriously I
like the song from the 80s it's like
it's awesome that it's like getting play
now because of stranger things and I
really liked like the scene that they
used it in because I did see stranger
things this season but in a way it's
kind of
I don't know it's I don't know how to
feel about it because now it's like
everybody's like oh everybody knows that
song now and I'm just like oh now it
happened with the Metallica song that's
in stranger things too oh yeah that's
like not your genre but if the same
thing happened where it's like oh God
like
it's like I don't know what to do and
it's like we were thinking I was
thinking about this last night too
because when we were at mannequins and
he played like a couple Marilyn Manson
songs
and you know I know a lot of people
especially people that got into goth in
the 90s and you know a lot of people
were into Marilyn Manson and I was like
and I was telling her I was like you
have to understand that like the people
that have been into it since the 80s we
were so mad at Marilyn Manson I was like
you ruined everything like why didn't
you do that so it's like even now I mean
well I mean now like obviously he's a
tool because like all the [__] that came
out about [__] that he did but I'm just
kind of like even back then I was just
kind of like bro just why did you have
to do why why so now everybody because
for a while in the 90s like if you
looked like a goth everybody was like oh
Marilyn Manson I'm like I don't even
listen to that it's like what the [__]
I wasn't a bunch of [__] you don't know
that's kind of honestly the Wednesday
thing now like I don't know like it's a
good show I like a lot of that too like
any girl that looks anything kind of if
you wear your dress or you do anything
it's like oh it's Wednesday yeah no and
I'm always yeah and I've been through it
so many times like in the 80s everyone
was like Hey Beetlejuice and I was like
no I looked like this before Beetlejuice
came out and then it was hey The Matrix
and I was like no I look like this
before the Matrix came out and it's just
so every time it's like it's always
shooting you just have to explain for
Tim Burton if you did anything that was
like oh yeah it's like a Tim Horton
character or something and that was
crazy because I remember because when
did Beetlejuice come out in 1988 and I
remember going to see a movie I don't
remember what movie it was though and
seeing the trailer for Beetlejuice and
I'm sitting there going what the [__]
can that really be a real movie I was
just like
wow I don't know how I feel about that
and so like I went to see it and I was
like oh awesome but I was like wait now
[__] and then it was like a big hit and
I was like it's it was awesome because
it was kind of the first time I don't
know it was the first time but it's the
first time that you saw like an actual
sort of accurate goth character that was
portrayed sympathetically like a real
person and we hadn't really seen that
like up to that point so I was like wow
it was like kind of mind-blowing oh that
she was like not normal but like you're
yeah sympathetic yeah she was just like
a regular person and it's like and she
was like a cool character like she was a
little bit exaggerated like for the
movie obviously but you know because
most real gods don't sit there and go my
whole life is a dark room although that
was like you know what yeah
I mean but that was like meant to be
funny so I was just like okay I got I
got you and it's like well I guess I
didn't mind it as much because Tim
Burton Tim Burton
um you know he grew up in that scene too
so he was familiar with all that you're
allowed to make fun of it if you're in
this so yeah so it's like I kind of feel
like you're kind of allowed to poke fun
because he knew that like other people
that we're into it would think it was
funny and like we did because I was just
like oh yeah that is pretty funny even
though I never knew a goth in real life
that was like that they're not super
depressed even though that seems to be I
don't know about nowadays but I kind of
feel like back in the old days that was
like kind of the Main
stereotype that people had about them
that they were just like yeah well
that's yeah I got that yeah really
depressed and suicidal or Satan or why
not both yeah yeah you're a depressed
Satanist but I was like really no not
any more than anybody else
I don't think I remember like in the 90s
like around 95 96 you started to get
what they call Perky goth remember that
yeah not not fondly but yeah I don't
know I thought it was good because they
were mixing it with things like hip hop
and trip hop and then you had
switchblade Symphony which that's what
that was
yeah and I thought that was a good Twist
on it
yeah I guess colors yeah I did like
switches I do like switchblades if
anything yeah and it was kind of like
kind of like real old Susie the way
certain songs were written you know like
things kind of sounded like the
Spellbound but then it would but then
they would put kind of like
trip hop [__] drum beat behind it so
it was better to dance to on a dance
floor
uh wearing white red hair
um
white hair
I remember when that [__] first appeared
in fact people just were calling that
[__] perky goth but that's mainstream
Gotham blue hair red hair now everybody
honestly anything goes with the seat
like that's what I mean you can get away
with that which is weird because like
back in the day you had to be really
careful like people that were in the
scene it's like oh I have it I have to
get a job I have to get a job interview
I have to cover up all my tattoos I have
to dye my hair I have to I can't wear
the makeup I normally wear like you had
to really really tone it down but like
now I feel like nobody cares which in a
way is good but the older people died
off and that's true of course the people
that complained about it yeah corporate
jobs were worried about lawsuits so you
just overwhelmed with the system or you
just like don't have a choice because I
think like tattoos I think I heard it's
like 40 something percent of the
population has at least one yeah like
lots so who are you gonna hire if yeah
like which is crazy again because the
first when I got my first one like the
tattoo artist is like you sure you want
it on your arm yeah it's like hide it
somewhere else yeah don't you want it
somewhere you can hide it like well you
can hide it on your arm because you can
wear long sleeves but I was just kind of
like
yeah like so I can get away with a
little bit more
Louis says my older cousin was into a
death rock group called the super
heroines yeah they're really good I like
them too I like them too uh Trey said I
love the cramps man I was listening to
them at Social Distortion today at work
I love the cramps too and Social
Distortion are also pretty awesome uh
Winterfell forever said Nina Hagen was a
[__] cool witch from hell is she
alive still yeah I think she is yeah
yeah I saw her and she said girl was
crazy yeah well when I saw her she was
she was crazy but like but it was an
awesome show though she was [__]
great is it Nina Hagen we're gonna [__]
yeah when I saw her live she was like
she was great
um Louie also said didn't recognize
Sophie with the blonde hair my real hair
this is real As It Gets
she's a honky ice princess
that is true oh it's Scandinavian
Bloodlines yeah
benjaminson yeah that's getting any
whiter than yeah yeah it can't get any
whiter than that yeah
grafter says how does mannequins compare
with Club Luna I know Luna is closed now
but that's the only Golf Club in
Michigan okay I've never been to Club
Luna because also like
like kind of a millennial like I'm only
31 so I I just float around between the
generations I'm not a baby but I'm not
like on their level so like we're not
old
she's like I'm not old like these old
books you've been in all these places
and stuff so like I have never heard I
think I've heard of Luna but I feel like
it was a dance club like if it was a
golf club it was way before my time but
no I've never been there
no idea yeah we I don't know if granters
was here when we talked about like being
at mannequins last night and getting in
two fights but yeah
listen to the beginning listen to the
beginning part yeah yeah you got the two
fights
scored two victories no losses so Jenny
got hurt running a dude's Bell so bad
that [__] on his way down his boy
back up he started beating her up
thinking it was me that's how [__]
that badly I had him [__] up it was
special and then afterwards I went
without looking for him but he was gone
kalon Higgins said was Beetlejuice
Winona Ryder's first movie I think her
first movie might have been Lucas when
she was a teenager Style
um but I wasn't Corey Haim in that I
kind of feel like Corey Haim was in that
maybe I'm imagining it but I remember
she was in it when she was a kid but I
don't think that that was like real
successful so I think that maybe
Beetlejuice was like her first like like
her breakout role but she had been in
movies prior to that John Smith said I
used to be really into Metallica until
the some kind of monster documentary
I want my rockstars Gods on top of a
mountain not profoundly emotionally
damaged men in group therapy
I still haven't because I'm not a big
Metallica fan but um so many people have
like told me about that documentary that
I'm outside I'm kind of curious because
I I like music biopics and I like music
documentaries even if it's a band that I
don't give a [__] about because [__] man
I think did we watch we we went through
like a spell like during a few week
period where we were just like watching
all these music documentaries that I
don't even give [__] if I like the band
or not it's just like I don't know
there's something about it is kind of
interesting to me so we watch stuff
about [__] journey and like all kind
of shitty ass pants
and it's like it was good so I I
wouldn't mind like watching the
Metallica One because I don't really
like Metallica no it's bad like but it
well it might be entertaining to watch
in a way it might be more entertaining
to watch because I don't really like
them so I don't really have a stake in
you know whether they come across as
like douchebags or not because I'm just
like I don't care I don't really like
like their music or anything all that
much so they're all right but it's not
really my thing so that's why
um oh [__] I got like way behind
yeah I think Heathers was also being
filmed at the time yeah oh man I love
Heather so that was such a great [__]
movie that was kind of like our that was
another movie that came out when I was
in high school
and I was kind of like oh my God this
movie was like
it seemed like it was made specifically
for
like the demographic of like me and my
friends because we were like the same
age as the characters in the movie were
supposed to be like at the time that it
came out and it was like our sense of
humor and I still think that movie is
[__] hilarious I think we reviewed it
not too long ago
Trey says uh I just stick to my tight
black jeans docs or wingtips and a band
or horror shirt and yeah you're good
you're good
uh Hugo said great show guys sadly gotta
go good night everybody all right good
to go in a bit too yeah because we're
going out uh a bit later so like in an
hour but I just yeah yeah
probably yeah John Smith said when I was
a kid the only people with tattoos were
Sailors and tough guys
yeah I kind of feel like even even up
until the 80s really I kind of feel like
the only people I don't know if the only
people with tattoos but I grew up in
Daytona and there's a lot of bikers so a
lot of bikers had tattoos so I kind of
feel like it was sort of associated with
bikers more than I mean now everybody's
got them and it's not like a deal way
back in the day wasn't like tattooed man
like a freak Show thing like yeah
although usually those people had
tattoos like all over their body but
still there's those but nowadays too
yeah now like you like you see people
with full sleeves and everything and
everyone's like meh no there's these new
um breed of goth girls one of them I
follow on um on Instagram
she's basically fully tattooed except
her face but her eyeballs are tattooed
too because they can do that she's an
artist and it's all tattooed with her
own art and she looks [__] great oh
yeah you showed me her yeah it does it
looks amazing it's very
done really well she looks it looks like
it's body paint or something and it's
just artwork different and it fades in
and out and there's patterns and it's a
it's really classy it looks really good
and it goes upper neck
and it stops in a router jawline and I
think it's got like little patterns that
look like little
Vines and tree limbs and stuff and it's
not real detailed it's which I think is
good because it doesn't look messy it
looks really clean
and there's another girl out there who's
nothing but long black triangles
all over her body but there there's
they're arranged in a way
to kind of accentuate her she she's real
well built probably like nine and she's
you know [__] slender body good fit
and everything accentuates her curves
and it's just this
big long triangle some of them three and
four feet long
starting in one place and heading in a
point somewhere else and it's just dug
really really well
so yeah you can have a tattooed woman
now
and it doesn't look like a tattooed
woman of the past it just looks like a
bunch of blue you know it doesn't it
well because that was like the shitty
ink that yeah and it faded and bled yeah
no it looks really good it looks uh
but like I said
you can't do those piecemeal basically
you have to start with a [__] road
map yeah you need an idea of what it's
going to look like all together yeah and
then you got to work on that for time
for over time because man that's a lot
of black it takes a long time yeah it's
okay good money yeah money yeah you're
like an investment you need like an
insurance policy all right A lot of the
things a lot of the tattooed people of
the past it was just done hodgepodge one
piece at a time until they all touched
each other it wasn't it wasn't any kind
of plan this thing what they're doing
now there's a whole [__] blueprint of
what it's going to look like I think
it which is that's how you plant you
plant murals that way you're just making
a 3D mural on a person looks good yeah
you're basically just making yourself
into a piece of art yep you know so you
have to like play it ahead I like that I
think it looks better yeah I don't like
and I don't begrudge anybody if you want
to get um you know just like tattoos
just over time like to commemorate
certain things because I know that a lot
of people do that but I kind of feel
like I don't know I'm the kind of person
that would like to sort of plan out what
it was going to look like just so
everything would work well together I
guess but
um Trey said when I was talking about
the the music documentaries he said I do
that too I read all kinds of rock and
roll biographies too yeah there's just
something about it I guess I'm because
I'm really into music in general and I
really like the music reading about the
music industry and reading about other
people's like stuff like that John Smith
also said there's a great documentary
about the Damned called don't you wish
we were dead now I that I need to see
because the Damned are super
entertaining uh and then he said I saw a
police officer with sleeve tattoos and
was mildly scandalized
is funny
well that's what I mean I kind of feel
like it's it's weird because it's
happened so quickly
in the 80s it was a big deal like and I
think more if you were a woman but it's
like if you were a Man Too like if you
had full sleeve tattoos and like I said
you had to go get a job somewhere like
in an office or something you would kind
of cover that [__] up and a lot of times
they would tell you well you have to
wear long sleeves like all the time yeah
like because we can't corporate for
uniform yeah like some little
blue-haired old lady is gonna come in
here and make no sense and call the
police on you have no sense in law
enforcement because a lot of the top
guys that they want out there in the
field are all ex-military so they're
going to have [__] Airborne tattoos
and [__] Dice and [__] Shamrocks
and anything associated with ever
military past and stuff's going to be
all over them American flags wrapped
around from unit Flags you see a lot of
that
I've seen cops with that in some of
those videos from that on that channel
of police activity
they're
which is nothing but just thousands and
thousands of police shootings [__]
fantastic fantastic Channel I love it
and it shows [__] just shootings and
unjust shootings they are not
discriminating because sometimes cops
are [__] up some of them just
I saw one a long time ago where they had
to do the rest of it on the ground and
they're like he's yelled I didn't do
nothing and he goes and he goes shut up
and he goes but I didn't do nothing he
goes get up and the guy got up and shot
him bow
he met shut up but he said get up
now dude got up yeah did exactly what he
was told dude shot him didn't kill him
though he got lucky
that's pretty [__] up yeah and the
dude the dude didn't do anything he was
an ex-arm he was not an exam he was an
army guy on [__] um
leave
in the back seat of his friend's car
and uh they thought the car was stolen
and it wasn't it was stolen
he was just one of the dudes in the back
arrest I think one of them ran and the
dude wasn't wanted for anything it's
just it was chaos you know some of those
arrests are chaos but it was kind of
slightly an unusual situation but it
turns out none of them were wanted for
anything none of them they were just
dumb
ER said 30 years ago tats were taboo for
cops and departments wouldn't hire
anyone with visible ink now unless
someone has like the SS bolts or
whatever it's normal for cops to be
tatted yeah and Louie says uh Tom knows
living in California as a youngster that
Mexican Americans started the whole
black and gray tattoos also known as
prison style tattoos I knew dudes that
were getting tattoos back in junior high
school and in our community women with
tattoos wasn't a big thing yeah yeah I
kind of feel like that that was a white
thing yeah I kind of feel like that was
a white person the most common was like
little roses and skulls and [__] like
that that's what the little Mexican
girls had those yeah yeah they were like
little cute skulls and
roses and stuff but yeah it's just it
was weird because I remember getting my
first tattoo which I don't have anymore
because I had it covered up with uh with
the the big one here but
um because I liked the tattoo it just
you know it was really old and faded but
I remember going to the tattoo shop
which was right by my grandmother's
house and it was all bikers you know
because it's Daytona that was like
mostly bikers that got tattoos and they
were kind of like weirded out because I
guess they didn't get a lot of women
especially that were just 18 or 19 years
old coming in there and wanting tattoos
like on their arm so they were trying to
like talk me out of it at first which I
thought was kind of funny but you know
whatever I always think too with that
corporate thing like a lot of people got
tattoos like to commemorate like someone
that died yeah and they'll put like a
date or a picture yeah so I'm like I
dare somebody to go into a job interview
and be like cover that up and you'd be
like that was my mom yeah it's like
Jesus Christ
it makes you look real cold like yeah
like after I said that I said yeah a lot
of a lot of those Mexican-American girls
had uh like basically meemaw's name yeah
yeah you're gonna discriminate against
that yeah
my dad has me and my siblings names on
his arms yeah like in cursive yeah all
right like the girls on one arm and the
boys on the other so it's past eight we
didn't shut it down yeah we gotta shut
it down because we're going out to
barbella tonight now tomorrow we
normally do a stream tomorrow like a
movie review so I don't know if we're
gonna do it or not we'll find out our
schedule's kind of thrown but you guys
understand what's going on I mean yeah
like if we watch a movie tomorrow or I
don't know we could just catch one
tomorrow it's gonna be damn black [__]
down yeah because yeah because Louie
sent that and it's like you know so we
want to review that too if we don't get
to it we might just do a Sidetrack show
or we'll I don't know we'll see how we
feel tomorrow but I'll announce it like
before we uh do anything but yeah so uh
thanks everybody for dropping by this
evening thank you for super chats and
doing the discussion and uh we'll see
you guys again possibly tomorrow if not
then uh then we'll do
Mondays right I gotta get back to the
boob Harem the boob Harem
yeah okay all right so we'll uh see you
guys again soon good